[MUSIC PLAYING]
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY:
Good afternoon.
Maestro Amjad Ali
Khan is synonymous
with Indian classical
music and, of course,
the mystical instrument
that he plays, the sarod.
He started playing the
sarod at an early age of 6.
And the rest, as
they say, is history.
And he's an amazing
award-winning performer,
whose appeal and
collaborations have transcended
borders, transcended genres.
And we also have the pleasure of
having his two sons, Amaan Ali
Bangash and Ayaan Ali
Bangash with us today.
These are also amazing
musicians in their own right.
And they're going to be
performing for us as well.
They have collaborated
together on several projects,
in addition to growing really
successful solo careers.
And it's quite an honor
for all of us-- for me--
to have them be with us in
this amazing new event center.
So I'd like all of you to stand
up and give Maestro Amjad Ali
Khan, Ayaan Ali Bangash,
and Amaan Ali Bangash
a big applause.
[APPLAUSE]
[SAROD STRUMMING]
AYAAN ALI BANGASH:
Good afternoon.
[HINDI] We'll present some
folk music from Bengal,
where we will also
present a song
by the iconic poet and
composer, the great [INAUDIBLE],,
followed by a
composition in Rag Durga.
Thank you so much.
[SAROD STRUMMING]
[CLASSICAL SAROD MUSIC]
Thank you so much.
Now, with utmost humility
and today's language,
I'd like to call onstage
#icon, #father, #maestro.
Please welcome Ustad
Amjad Ali Khasa.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[CLASSICAL SAROD MUSIC]
AMJAD ALI KHAN: While
playing the sarod,
I'm not pressing the
string with my fingertips.
While it's played with
fingertips-- cello, sitar--
but if I play sarod
with fingertips,
it will sound like this.
[PLUCKING SAROD]
So this is the
sound of fingertips.
But to bring out the
human expressions,
the vocal expressions, I have to
press the string with the edge
of my fingernails.
You can see the difference.
[PLUCKING SAROD]
[STRUMMING SAROD]
Most of the songs--
they are based on
language, text, lyrics.
But in 13th century,
Hazrat Amir Khusro,
a Sufi saint who created
[INAUDIBLE] called Qalbana.
He created a style of
singing called Tarana.
So Tarana doesn't deal with
language or lyrics or text.
So he created a language
of music, language
of syllables and sound.
[TARANA SOUNDS]
Just two compositions
I would like to sing--
9 and 1/2 beat.
[TARANA SINGING]
[SAROD MUSIC]
The other kind of Tarana--
[TARANA SINGING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY:
Akhansa, you come
from a long line of musicians
and classical performers.
AMJAD ALI KHAN: Yes.
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY:
In fact, I've heard
that the instrument
sarod, itself, came
from their forefathers.
Can you tell us a little
bit about the instrument?
AMJAD ALI KHAN: Yes,
actually, "sarod"
is a Persian word which
means music, not [INAUDIBLE]..
And my forefathers, they
came from Afghanistan,
[INAUDIBLE] India.
And my forefathers,
they were rabab players.
The rabab is a Afghan
instrument, in Kashmir, also--
Central Asia.
So they modified
from rabab to sarod.
And there are nearly
500 sarod players, now,
all over the world.
And they are all connected.
Whoever is playing
sarod, they were taught
by my forefathers, [INAUDIBLE].
There are so many names.
So they are the
seventh generation
of [INAUDIBLE], of our family.
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY:
That's wonderful.
[APPLAUSE]
You played solo for us.
It was such an amazing treat.
You also performed
with your sons.
How do the different
experiences compare?
AMJAD ALI KHAN: You see,
by the grace of God,
they have their own mission,
their own vision of music.
Amaan's approach of
music is different.
Ayaan's approach is different.
And sometimes, they play duet.
Sometimes, we play
three of us together.
AMAAN ALI BANGASH: We
like to accompany him.
AMJAD ALI KHAN: And also,
they are invited now
for solo recitals.
Because to be alone on the stage
is most challenging and most
satisfying creative-wise.
So [INAUDIBLE]
music is our life.
Music is of our real expression.
And we live in the
world of sound.
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY:
That's wonderful.
It's wonderful.
I have a question for you, Amji.
You perform all
around the world,
often to people that haven't
really heard the sarod before--
for the first time.
How do you connect
with your audiences?
AMAAN ALI BANGASH: Well,
I think the first thing
is to have a positive
attitude, never to believe--
I would always want
to be a student.
If I have bad days,
I have good days.
But the audience, for me,
is a mirror of my being,
in terms of--
there's no point
getting an award
and getting an empty house.
I'd rather not get an award
and have a full house.
So for me, I see God
through the audience,
because that is the biggest
award a musician can get.
And to play to a new audience
is always more challenging.
But its also more fun.
Because you can do certain
things that you cannot do when
the, quote, unquote, "real"
connoisseurs are there.
So it's a nice feeling.
And you are, all the
time, constantly learning.
And I don't take
myself very seriously.
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY:
That's wonderful.
I have two sons.
They're teenagers now.
And I least my memory
of them growing up
is doing various things with
them, whether it's puzzles
or-- now they're 16 and 18.
So we actually do programming
projects together.
I'm a software engineer.
Ayaan, you have young sons.
Do you play with them?
Or do you see them
becoming musicians?
AYAAN ALI BANGASH:
Well, they're 5.
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY:
How old are they?
Excuse me.
AYAAN ALI BANGASH:
They're 5 and 1/2.
They're twins-- Zohan and Abid.
So while they seem to be
interested, right now,
it's just a lot of noise.
Because they have
two little sarods.
And there's a lot of
strumming that happens.
But then, they're
very fortunate.
I've handed them over, at the
moment, to the grandfather.
I said, the moment
they get somewhere,
then I think I'll get in.
But then, they're
very fortunate.
Because, I think, they
also have this atmosphere
of music around them.
And music, actually,
is the greatest wealth
that we have in our family.
So I think, for us, it's a
way of life, not a profession.
It's a passion.
So I think it's not something
outside the box that's
happening.
But again, no pressure.
They are free to do
what they want to do.
But it's a long
journey for any--
not just a classical
musician, but anyone creative.
I think you need to have
the passion, the patience,
the faith, the belief.
And eventually, destiny has
its own plans sometimes.
But anyway, they're
very fortunate that they
have the grandfather.
There's the uncle.
There's the father.
So there's a lot of
music around them.
So they're enjoying
the attention.
But let's see what happens.
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY: And--
AYAAN ALI BANGASH: They
need your blessings--
all your blessings.
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY: Oh,
they'll do very good.
And when did the
two of you decided
you wanted to be musicians?
Do you remember a particular
point in time when you said,
this is our calling?
AMAAN ALI BANGASH: Well,
I was the mischievous one.
I was not into music
till a certain age,
though I was introduced to
the sarod and-- you know.
By the time I was about 12,
13, I had a very bad show,
where I saw my father,
actually, embarrassed of me.
It was a show in London.
And that's when, I
think, my world changed.
I realized where God has sent
me and what I have to do.
But then it became--
AMJAD ALI KHAN: I had
fever on that night.
AMAAN ALI BANGASH: Yeah.
AYAAN ALI BANGASH: Yes.
AMAAN ALI BANGASH: So
you know the pressures--
AYAAN ALI BANGASH: It
Was as simple as that.
AMAAN ALI BANGASH: So
especially when you're
born to people like my father--
so people do believe.
And it's fair enough
for everyone to believe
that the ride is much easier.
But as they say,
there's no free lunches.
There are none.
Being born to people
like him, what happens
is that, though you get
a lot of advantages,
you get a lot of appreciation
and attention from people.
I would have taken
another 20 years,
I think, if I was not his
son, to reach whatever little
or whatever-- achieved--
or I'm on my way.
But the pressures are very high.
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY: Expectations.
AMAAN ALI BANGASH: Yeah,
so I think, coming back
to the question-- sorry.
So when I saw that about
my father, I think,
took life seriously.
And I valued
education and sarod.
And I knew that sarod
was the best that I had.
Because tabla-- I
was very bad at it.
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY:
How about you, Ayaan?
AYAAN ALI BANGASH:
Well, I don't think
I had any defining
moment, so to speak.
In the sense, I always knew
that this is what I want to do.
This is what my
heart wanted to do.
But obviously,
there was that time
when I was just about
to finish high school
and all my friends were
doing their Dartmouths
and their Whartons and
Stanfords-- all that
was happening-- their SATs.
So that moment, that was just,
maybe, a temporary moment.
I just questioned myself.
Am I heading towards
the right direction?
Because, the end of the
day, you don't know.
You only know that
you don't know.
So I actually, obviously,
internally thought about it.
I spoke to my
parents, who've always
been one of the most
influential people in my life.
So they said, like
I said earlier,
my father said, I shared
with both of you what
was the greatest thing I had.
And beyond this, he says that
I wouldn't have taught you
if I didn't see you responding
to music in the right way.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
I mean, I was no Mozart.
But having said that,
it's a long journey.
But the thing is, he said,
you are on the right track.
And I think you should be
OK-- or you will be OK.
So faith in the
guru, faith in God.
And it's hard work.
And it's just a long way.
We're starting a new
journey every day.
AMJAD ALI KHAN: I remember when
they were about 12-years-old,
they came to me and
asked me, out of them,
who should not play sarod.
AYAAN ALI BANGASH: Did we?
AMJAD ALI KHAN: So I
said, I'm just a guru.
I'm not [INAUDIBLE].
I'm not a god.
If you have connection
with sound and rhythm,
that means it's a wish of God
that you both should play sarod
or you should be in the music.
So you can't promote music.
You can't-- it's
not a commodity.
So it grows on you.
And thank god we belong
to the world of sound.
Because through sound, we
cannot manipulate our life.
And the other world is language.
With all due
respect to language,
I often feel that language
could not create compassion
and kindness in a human being.
Even today, we are killing each
other on account of religion.
It's very sad.
And my father, he was not
teaching me only music
but a complete way of life.
And he often said that all
of us have a common god
and we are the common race.
Because I wish
this message should
had been conveyed by all the
priests of all the religions.
But every priest has
their own agenda.
They are also getting
monthly salaries.
More so, it is up to us.
We have to realize how
we come to the world
and how we go away
from this world.
It's the same passage.
So we are in the same race.
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY: That's
a wonderful message.
AYAAN ALI BANGASH: And just on
another note, we are not twins.
I just wanted to clarify.
AMAAN ALI BANGASH: Yes.
AYAAN ALI BANGASH:
Just wanted to settle--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AMJAD ALI KHAN: --twinish.
AYAAN ALI BANGASH:
And after I had twins,
people just think
that we are twins.
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY: That's funny.
AMJAD ALI KHAN:
And also, I wanted
to share that lot of people
compare Indian music with jazz
music.
Yes, jazz musicians
also improvise.
But they have the
complete freedom
to use all the 12 notes,
whenever they want.
But we don't have
that kind of freedom.
We have to improvise
within the set rule
of ascending and descending.
But improvisation is
not such a great thing.
Even a child can improvise.
Our salient features of
our Indian classical music
is slides and glides.
In Hindi, we call it [HINDI].
[VOCALIZATION]
It's a precious gift
from God to our music.
[VOCALIZATION]
So ornamentation and
the slides and glides--
so now, music has
become therapy also.
A lot of diseases can
be cured by music.
And plants grow
faster with music.
Even cattles give
more milk by listening
to certain kind of music.
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY:
That's wonderful.
You are an inspiration to all
of us with your virtuosity.
How much do you still practice?
What is your [INAUDIBLE]
routine like every day now?
AMJAD ALI KHAN:
You see, earlier, I
was giving more time,
sometimes, all night.
And my father was
very, very old,
because I was the youngest
child of their family.
So I had elder
brothers and uncles.
But the sense of
responsibility--
for any child to realize
their responsibility
is the greatest day
for the parents.
So my father-- sometimes,
middle of the night,
he saw me practicing--
he will come and tell me,
[HINDI],, now go to sleep.
So that was the father.
But he was a hard
taskmaster while teaching.
And he was very famous.
He was very revered.
And he got all the
awards and all that--
but a saintly person,
committed to God
and committed to
purity of music.
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY:
That's wonderful.
So I think we have two
questions recorded on video.
Can we roll them?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Hi, I'm Akash, a Googler
here in the Mountain View
office on the finance team.
I'm a longtime fan of yours.
And I'm glad you can
make it here today.
My question for you is that,
in the decades of you playing
the sarod, would you say
that your music has evolved
over the years to adapt to the
various audiences you perform
to, given the increasing
globalization in fusion music?
Thank you.
[END PLAYBACK]
AMJAD ALI KHAN: Let's all reply
one-by-one, this question.
You start, Ayaan.
AYAAN ALI BANGASH: Oh--
OK.
AMJAD ALI KHAN: No, no.
AYAAN ALI BANGASH:
It's addressed to you.
But--
AMJAD ALI KHAN:
Let's have our views.
AYAAN ALI BANGASH:
Well, of course,
I can speak for my father
here, because the question was
addressed to him.
As a student, not
just as a son, I
think he is one of those
masters in the field who
have been extremely
progressive with the way
he has gone about
his musical approach.
If you hear my father in the
'60s or in the '70s, '80s,
'90s now, I think, there,
you can see a journey.
And you can see a
different thought process
over the period of time.
And today, my father's vision--
I think he's playing
shorter pieces now.
He's focusing more
on compositions.
He's focusing more on
certain elements of music.
Of course, it's him.
It's the same artist.
But I think, today, it's him
with that entire journey, which
he's just sharing
with the world.
And I think, it's just really
interesting to see that.
And I think, yes, seeing
even the current situation,
I don't think he's
made any compromises
to the traditional
aspect of music.
Because I don't
think any books said
how to present classical music.
I think he's done things a
little bit outside the box.
And I think it's working very
well with the music lovers,
as always.
And this was not my question.
So my father should answer.
AMAAN ALI BANGASH:
And you should answer.
He's our father.
AMJAD ALI KHAN: You see, because
now the whole voice has become
so intolerant and impatient.
And everything should
happen quickly.
People become musicians to
just perform or to create a CD
or to go to a reality show.
And most of the musicians
today, you see, they're
all standing and performing--
in such a rush, such a hurry.
Our tradition is that we have
to sit and play and sing.
And my father often said
that we must see good points
at every system of
music, whether it
is folk music, European
music, any music.
And in our country, we have
so many states and regions.
And through a line
of melody, a region
can be introduced--
a folk music.
The folk music of Rajasthan--
[VOCALIZATION]
So this is folk
music, most ancient.
Because classical was created.
It is formalized.
It wasn't there in--
so folk music, folk dance,
is the most original form
of music of any country.
And then, one day,
I received a message
from Scottish Chamber Orchestra.
They wanted me to write a
piece for their orchestra.
And as we always say,
we don't read and write.
So I sang in a CD all my
vision and expressions
for the orchestra.
Then, I found one conductor--
a British conductor.
He knew my mind.
So he wrote everything.
So now, we have a written score.
And the piece is
called Samaagam.
Samaagam means
Conference of Culture.
So many orchestras of the world,
they are playing my piece.
This is the first sarod
concerto in the world.
There are three of us play
with 60, 70 musicians around.
And I hope, one day, we
could perform that orchestra,
Samaagam, for you also.
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY:
That's amazing.
That sounds like
an amazing treat.
I think we have one more
video question from Jocelyn.
Let's roll that.
JOCELYN: Hello, I'm Jocelyn,
from Google, Mountain View.
My team focuses on
building products
for the emerging Indian market.
We're so very honored to
have you with us here today.
So thank you.
My question is this.
We here at Google are
very proud of Google Play.
Has the digital music
industry changed the way
you approach your craft?
And how do you engage with
the millennial audience?
Thank you.
AMJAD ALI KHAN: Would
you like to talk some?
AMAAN ALI BANGASH: Well, I think
it's more approachable today,
thanks to the things
going digital.
[INAUDIBLE] remember,
when we were growing up--
we're still growing actually,
but when we were growing up
and were much younger--
we would battle with
other musicians,
like, on a friendly--
give me that cassette.
I'll give you that cassette,
that recording, or that LP,
or that--
or we would hide and
record sometimes,
with that small tape recorder.
Because that was
the access we would
have to a musician's
vision of music.
Today, it's so much
easier for people.
Technically, I think
some musicians don't even
have a guru now.
The laptop is the
guru, in a good way.
You press, I want
to learn Rag Kidara.
You press that button.
And you have 50,000
recordings coming out.
AMJAD ALI KHAN: Of Kidara?
AMAAN ALI BANGASH: Of Kidara--
of different musicians.
So it's a good
thing, at some level.
It's a good thing.
And I think, for musicians,
it become a bit tough,
not for people like him,
but for people like us.
That when we have a
repertoire of ragas--
let's say I know 25
ragas or 30 ragas.
Now, someone is recording it.
So today, I've played
here at Google.
And let's say, tomorrow,
I'm playing, for example,
at San Jose.
I cannot repeat the same
rag or the same [INAUDIBLE],,
because somebody
will record there.
And you know, oh, this guy
doesn't have a repertoire.
He has played [? daesh ?]
today-- rag daesh--
and he's again playing
Rag Daesh tomorrow.
So it's making us--
everyone is on the edge.
And everyone's actually
bringing their game up.
Because there's
more transparency.
And it's a good thing.
I think it was changing and--
AMJAD ALI KHAN: But I think,
you should not feel that way.
You must know what is your best.
You can play 100
times Rag Kidara.
It will be different.
AMAAN ALI BANGASH:
No, but I have
other rags that I can play.
So--
AYAAN ALI BANGASH:
It's more difficult
for stand-up comedians.
They can't repeat their jokes.
AMAAN ALI BANGASH:
Yeah, exactly.
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY: Right.
AMJAD ALI KHAN:
Did you two think--
actually, a great gift,
also, to all of us.
And I'm proud of human beings
who have created mobile phones
and iPads and all those--
keyboard.
The keyboard is a
amazing instrument
that people can produce sound
of flute, sound of drum,
and sitar, and so many--
violins and cello.
AYAAN ALI BANGASH:
Not sarod yet--
[INAUDIBLE]
AMJAD ALI KHAN:
And not sarod yet.
I'm sure, one day, we can hear
sarod also through keyboard.
But our music-- classical
music-- has been documented,
because of digi--
AYAAN ALI BANGASH:
Digitalization.
AMAAN ALI BANGASH:
AMJAD ALI KHAN:
--digitalization.
So because we cannot perform
identical next concert the way
we play, whatever we
have played today--
again, if we play
the same pieces,
the expression
would be different.
So if we are recorded so you
can listen to it 1,000 times--
and I feel that some
musicians boast about--
they know 1,000
raga or 2,000 raga.
But the great
maestros, they became
famous because of 3-minutes
record-- that 78 RPM.
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY: Right.
AMJAD ALI KHAN:
That three minutes--
the music is the
name of quantity.
It doesn't matter how
many ragas you know.
But even if you know four
ragas which are appealing,
which are soothing and
give you pleasure--
so music should be appealing.
And that is most important.
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY: Do you
have any audience questions?
I have an endless list to ask.
AMJAD ALI KHAN: Feel free
to us whatever you want to.
AUDIENCE: [SANSKRIT]--
AMJAD ALI KHAN: Just take
the mic down a little.
AUDIENCE: Welcome
again to Google.
So my question was, obviously,
music was in the family.
You were introduced
very early on.
And sarod was obvious
choice, probably.
But do you play other
instruments for fun?
Or just pick things up?
AMAAN ALI BANGASH: It's for him?
AUDIENCE: What do you play?
AMJAD ALI KHAN: You should--
AUDIENCE: For you two.
And of course, [INAUDIBLE]
AMJAD ALI KHAN: You
start from Ayaan.
AYAAN ALI BANGASH: Well,
I can strum the guitar.
I can just,
literally, play around
with the guitar, because
I play the sarod.
And when you have the
frets it's easier.
I can play around
with the sitar.
It's those fun moments.
It's not something I'm proud of.
But obviously, we've had--
I can play some compositions.
We've heard so much music of
all my father's contemporaries.
So we know how they would
hold the instrument, how--
these were our heroes, along
with my father, all his--
AMJAD ALI KHAN: May I interrupt?
AYAAN ALI BANGASH: --all
his contemporaries.
Yes.
AMJAD ALI KHAN:
From his childhood,
he was interested in painting.
AYAAN ALI BANGASH:
Well, that too.
AMJAD ALI KHAN: So always
the images of Lord Ganesha.
And even his [INAUDIBLE]--
that is his passion also.
And he's involved
in painting also.
Yes, what about you?
AMAAN ALI BANGASH: No--
so you were saying--
AYAAN ALI BANGASH: No, no.
So that's pretty much it-- yes.
AMAAN ALI BANGASH: So I think
sarod was an obvious choice--
sorry-- [INAUDIBLE]
was an obvious choice,
because there was
so much around it.
It's like, when you're in
the middle of the ocean,
you have to swim.
There's no other option.
But I enjoy playing
the tabla a little bit.
AYAAN ALI BANGASH: He
plays very well, actually.
AMAAN ALI BANGASH: But just,
like, [INAUDIBLE] tabla,
we call it.
AYAAN ALI BANGASH: Yeah,
a sample sound check--
AMAAN ALI BANGASH: I'm OK--
AYAAN ALI BANGASH:
--we'll have in a moment.
AMAAN ALI BANGASH: --with a
bit of piano and composing
some sort of songs and
all, and a bit of santoor.
So it's there, but
it's not something
that I can do it in
front of all of you.
But it's like, a
bathroom singer.
AYAAN ALI BANGASH:
Private moments-- yes.
AMAAN ALI BANGASH: But
sarod was an obvious choice.
AMJAD ALI KHAN: And I was
so much involved with tabla.
I used to play tabla as
a child, and so tabla
that my father got worried.
He thought I might become only
tabla player, not sarod player.
So he hid the tabla
for a long time.
AMAAN ALI BANGASH:
He was tabla sick.
AMJAD ALI KHAN: But
I'm so much involved.
I enjoy playing tabla
in my free time.
And I compose also--
songs, [INAUDIBLE],, and
music for the ballet,
music for the orchestra.
And it's very interesting
how the industry works--
even in Bombay,
film or Bollywood--
that first, there is a tune.
That tune is sent
to the lyricist.
And then he wires the words.
Like, I composed one song--
[VOCALIZATION] So this is the
[INAUDIBLE] the first piece.
And the lyricist wrote--
AMAAN ALI BANGASH: [INAUDIBLE]--
AYAAN ALI BANGASH: I don't
remember the words-- yeah.
AMJAD ALI KHAN: "Dun"--
anyway, so this is the--
we always forget the language,
the words, the lyrics.
Because our life is
full of sound and music.
And in our traditional
families, we
were not allowed
to plan our future.
It's an unwise thing to do.
But that is the commitment
the guru demands, that one
has to surrender to gurus.
One has to surrender to God.
And rest-- leave it to God.
We don't know what is
going to happen tomorrow.
So there was our way of life
of Indian classical musicians.
It's almost like entering
into a dark tunnel
with the hope of
sun-rays someday.
So very few can make it.
And there are thousands of
musicians in that journey.
But my father--
we depend on God.
And so whatever has happened,
with the love and blessings
of the people of India,
people of the world,
people who love music--
and I'm grateful to
God that Amaan, Ayaan--
they are so committed
and dedicated.
And they are very
fortunate to have
a mother like Subhalakshmi.
My wife, she was a very
famous Bharatanatyam dancer.
And because we both are
unemployed parents-- so we
gave a lot of time to them.
AMAAN ALI BANGASH: Basically,
the answer to your question
is, we didn't have a
choice with the sarod.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hello, sir,
long back in an interview,
I'd seen that while training
Amaan and Ayaan, when you were
traveling, probably,
you would hum a tune,
and they wouldn't map
the [INAUDIBLE] to it.
AMJAD ALI KHAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you still do that?
And if possible, can
we have a demo of that?
AMJAD ALI KHAN: You're putting
us through a test again.
AUDIENCE: Because I was in awe
when I saw that [INAUDIBLE]..
So yeah, I don't mind
being awe-struck again.
AMJAD ALI KHAN:
You see, every guru
has a different way of teaching.
But I feel that, more than the
language or lyrics and text,
if you are a musician, you must
be connected with the sound
first.
Like-- Ayaan--
[TARANA SINGING,
CALL & RESPONSE]
AMAAN ALI BANGASH: Why
did you ask this question?
AMJAD ALI KHAN: We need to
do some questions with you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
AMJAD ALI KHAN: It's
like Musical Quiz.
AYAAN ALI BANGASH: [INAUDIBLE]
AMJAD ALI KHAN: So then--
AYAAN ALI BANGASH: We
haven't done this in a while.
AMJAD ALI KHAN: As children,
they used to do that.
Now, we communicate
through instruments only.
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY: Please.
AUDIENCE: Earlier, you mentioned
that your guru would ask
you to surrender to the music.
Those are the kind
of gurus that day.
But I think, nowadays, it's hard
to find those kind of gurus.
It's mostly, like, for earning.
Any tips on that?
Like, how to get a good
guru and get into the music?
Yeah-- any tips?
AMJAD ALI KHAN: There are
lots of gurus all over India,
all over the world.
The point is, in our
country, a learned,
learned man was
considered a institution.
And now, a huge cemented
building is called institution.
So that is the basic difference.
The institution, that
knowledgeable man--
they used to be very demanding.
And some gurus were very
sincere to their disciples.
And some gurus are
not very sincere.
We have a history
of the [INAUDIBLE]----
AMAAN ALI BANGASH: That's right.
AMJAD ALI KHAN: --and--
AYAAN ALI BANGASH:
And [INAUDIBLE]----
AMAAN ALI BANGASH: [INAUDIBLE]--
AMJAD ALI KHAN: [INAUDIBLE].
AMAAN ALI BANGASH: [INAUDIBLE].
AMJAD ALI KHAN: So we
have that kind of history
that, sometimes, guru is not
very partial or impartial.
So some students
become more favorite.
Some students-- they
don't want to teach them.
But it's very,
very, very important
to have right kind of
guidance and gurus.
AMAAN ALI BANGASH: But no,
he was asking-- if I may--
how to find a guru.
AYAAN ALI BANGASH: You
can, of course, Google it.
That's one thing.
But no, seriously-- I think--
AMJAD ALI KHAN:
Now, it is, people
are teaching through Skype.
AYAAN ALI BANGASH:
On that, I think
it depends as to
where you want to go.
Say, if you're learning
for the love of music,
that's one thing.
If you're learning because
it's a passion, it's one thing.
If you're learning because you
want to make a profession out
of this, then
that's another way.
Then you have to learn
the way it was learned.
You have to go to a teacher.
You have to be a part
of that teacher's life
and be around your
teacher and learn.
But obviously, online
classes are happening now.
It's also convenience.
A lot of people have
passion, but they are
unable to take that time out.
So there are so many kinds
of gurus available now.
But it depends which,
I think, direction
you want to head towards.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMJAD ALI KHAN:
Very few students
are learning music
to understand music
and to understand the
depth of the music.
Because most of the
learners, the students,
young performers-- they all
want to perform on the stage.
So this impatientness to
be on the stage, that's
the greatest destruction.
It's a tragedy of music.
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY:
Well, we could
do this for a very long time.
But our time is up.
It's not often that
one has the privilege
to be right next to a
living legend of India.
Khansa, Amaan, Ayaan--
thank you all so much.
AYAAN ALI BANGASH: Thank you.
AMAAN ALI BANGASH:
Thank you for having us.
AMJAD ALI KHAN: Thank you.
AYAAN ALI BANGASH:
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]